في حملته ادعائيه كمرشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه يضع زعيم المعارضه صور رئيسي
بلديتي انقره واسطنبول الى جانب صورته لما
لهما من شعبيه في الشارع وهو ما يعيد نفس
السؤال الاول لدى جمهور المعارضه من الذي
كان ينبغي ان يترشح لمنافسه اردوغان زعيم
المعارضه ام احد رئيسي بلديتي انقره او
اسطنبول
قاده تحالف الامه او الطاوله السداسيه
قرروا ترشيح كمال كينجدار اوغلو بعد
اعتراض وانسحاب زعيمه حزب الخير ميرال
اكشنر مقابل عوده اكشنر مجددا للتحالف
تقرر تعيين رئيسي بلديه اسطنبول وانقره
كنواب للرئيس للاستفاده من شعبيتهما في
الحملات الانتخابيه وعمليات جذب الاصوات
المؤيده لهما
الى جانبك يشارك رئيس بلديه اسطنبول وانقر
في الحمله الانتخابيه وينحدر الرئيسان من
حزبنا كما تعلمون بهذا الفريق نرى ان
اسهمنا الانتخابيه تتجه نحو ايصال مرشحنا
السيد كليجدار اوغلو لمنصب الرئاسه
ويضم تحالف الامه احزابا يساريه وقوميه
واسلاميه تساندها احزاب شق مؤسسوها عن حزب
العداله والتنميه هذه القوى السياسيه
اجتمعت كلها على خصومه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان لذا كان البرنامج الانتخابي لهم
يتمثل في الغاء كل ما جاء به اردوغان
كالغاء النظام الرئاسي والعوده الى النظام
البرلماني المعزز والغاء العديد من
الهيئات والمؤسسات التي انشاها اردوغان
ولم يهمل قاده التحالف القضيه الاساسيه
التي تفقد خصمهم رصيده في الشارع الا وهي
التضخم والوضع الاقتصادي المتازم خلال
السنوات الماضيه قمنا باعداد وثيقه تتالف
من 2300 ماده وايضا لدينا وثيقه اعاده
تطبيق النظام البرلماني عبر اجراء تعديلات
دستوريه هذه الوثائق ستتضمن عمليه التغيير
المرجوه رغم ذلك ارى انه من الطبيعي ان
تطرا خلافات بين الفينه والاخرى داخل
تحالف سياسي يضم سته احزاب سياسيه تختلف
فكريا كثير من معارضي هذا التحالف يراهنون
على هشاشه العلاقه بين الاحزاب المنضويه
فيه ويؤكدون ان ازمه اختيار مرشح مشترك
تمثل تجربه اولى لتلك الاحزاب ستعقبها
تجارب واختبارات اخرى في حال وصلت
المعارضه الى السلطه اما مؤيد التحالف
فيؤكدون ان الخلافه لا يفسد ود السياسه
لكن الجميع يتفق ان قاده التحالف ارتبط
مصيرهم بهذه الانتخابات فاما نصر يخلدهم
في صفحات السياسه التركيه او خروج من
المشهد السياسي ومن الباب الضيق زيدان
زنكلو العربيه اسطنبول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات